Стоси зібраних матеріалів, а серед них - відписки від військової прокуратури.
Адвокатка Анна Брицька веде резонансну справу
про сексуальні домагання до лейтенантки Валерії Сікал.
Взимку 2019 року молода військова не побоялась на всю країну
розповісти про те, як керівник, полковник Віктор Іванів,
за просування по службі змушував її до сексу.
За словами жінки, знущання почалися у перший день служби,
і саме цей випадок тепер розслідується у кримінальному провадженні.
Приказом сказав: сідай в машину.
Я сіла. І ми поїхали.
Я не знала місцевості.
Коли приїхали в будиночок, він почав знову обіймати, прижимати до себе,
як ніби я його жінка. Я мушу це робити.
Я стою і говорю, що мені це не подобається. Я не та, яку можна лапати, трогати…
Слідство веде райвідділ поліції Хмельницької області.
На думку адвокатки зібрано достатньо доказів.
Далі за процедурою,  перевірити, підписати
та направити свідчення до суду має військова прокуратура.
Але вже двічі прокурор військової прокуратури Рівненського гарнізону Юрій Рижий
завертає справу назад до поліції.
По першим вказівкам, які він дав слідству, складалось враження,
що він справу і не читав.
Тому що вказівки стосувались тих моментів, які були вже зроблені слідством.
А прокурор навіть її не прогортав, при тому, що він протримав її протягом двох місяців.
Другий раз справа лежала два місяці у військовій прокуратурі,
уже з направленою підозрою, і він знову направив назад,
сказав, що вона є передчасною, і написав додаткові вказівки.
Але вони не стосуються події злочину.
В результаті затягування військовою прокуратурою справи спливли строки
притягнення до кримінальної відповідальності підозрюваного.
Згідно з українським законодавством, з дня вчинення злочину
має минути не більше двох років.
Тож ймовірний кривдник може залишитись без покарання.
На мій погляд, це бездіяльність прокуратури.
Це небажання брати відповідальність підписувати підозру.
Вони з одного боку не закривають провадження за відсутністю складу
кримінального правопорушення і в той же час не підписують підозру.
Тобто справа в повітрі. Бо і оскаржити нічого.
Це в подальшому стане підставою до звернення до Європейського суду
і говорити про неефективність розслідування.
Тим часом сам полковник Віктор Іванів навіть не був відсторонений від служби.
Натомість його перевели з військової частини на Хмельниччині до Києва.
На запит DW в Мінобороні відповіли, що йдеться не про підвищення,
а про переведення на рівнозначну посаду.
Таке рішення міністерства обурило колишню військову Валерю Сікал.
Адже за результатами внутрішньої перевірки Військової служби правопорядку
встановлено особи інших жінок-військових, щодо яких Іванів теж поводився аморально.
Деякі військові навіть звільнилися через негідні дії керівника.
Встановлені також випадки, коли Іванів з так би мовити "виховною" метою
ставив клізми військовим, яких підозрював у вживанні алкоголю.
Полковник знімав це на відео та шантажував підлеглих.
Я шокована, що у нас все так робиться, замість того, щоб людину хоча б відсторонити
від обов'язків, його переводять на таку ж саму посаду...
але ж йде досудове розслідування і, як не крути, кримінальне провадження відкрите.
Отже, підстави для відкриття кримінального провадження були,
а щоб відсторонити від обов'язків - немає? Це абсурд… Просто закрили очі.
Та поки розгляд кримінальної справи проти Іваніва затягується військовою прокуратурою,
в суді нині розглядається інша - цивільна справа проти Валерії Сікал
та деяких журналістів.
Полковник Іванів вважає, що ті порушили його честь та гідність.
DW спробувала уточнити у адвоката підозрюваного, Ігоря  Шкодяка, суть цієї справи.
- Справа ще слухається в суді відповідно ніяких коментарів не буде.
Буде рішення суду, тоді будемо говорити.
- Ми б хотіли дізнатись, як була порушена честь і гідність.
- Суд приймає  рішення і, я надіюсь, законне. Ви ж громадянка України?
Ви вірете в українські суди? Ми віримо.  Суд прийме законне рішенні
і тоді будемо все бачити.
Щороку за неофіційною статистикою Військової служби правопорядку на гарячі лінії Міноборони
телефонує один-два військових, які стають жертвами сексуальних домагань.
Служба проводить внутрішні перевірки та у разі складу злочину передає справи до поліції
чи інших відповідних органів.
Втім, жодних судових рішень винесено не було.
В службі впевнені, що ситуація може змінитись, якщо будуть проведені реформи
і їй нададуть повноваження виконувати досудове слідство.
Ми намагаємось підготувати і провести через Верховну раду закон
про військову поліцію, в якому буде надані повноваження проведення досудового слідства,
які стосуються військових злочинів.
Це система реформування по стандартам країн НАТО, система військової поліції,
в яку, сподіваємось, найближчим часом буде реформована Військова служба правопорядку
і отримані всі необхідні функції.
Втім, кому буде підпорядковуватись нова служба, поки невідомо.
Андріана Арехта, лідерка Жіночого ветеранського руху, переконана,
що нічого не зміниться, якщо реформована Військова служба правопорядку
залишиться в структурі Міноборони.
Тож виступає за створення незалежного від військового командування органу
- Інституту військового омбудсмена.
Саме туди зі своїми скаргами мали б звертатися військові.
Чому? Тому що з того,  що говорять військовослужбовці - подзвонити на гарячу лінію
- це бути "шісткою" в своїй системі.
Це теж ще з радянського. Якщо ти зателефонував і сказав, що твої права порушені,
у тебе відразу порушуються статутні відносини з твоїм командуванням військової частини.
Валерія Сікал та її адвокатка Анна Брицька націлені йти до кінця.
Врешті, якщо війькова прокуратура вирішить, що цей випадок не тягне на статтю 154.
- Примушування до вступу в статевий зв'язок
і закриє справу - потерпіла спершу оскаржить рішення прокуратури в українському суді
а далі звернеться до Європейського суду з прав людини.